if if your vision of the last decade of  your life is to be surrounded by  family who love you and want to be  around you  but 40 years earlier you have no  relationships you're you know your kids  hate you because you're  a jerk and you're working all the time  there's a disconnect like  why do you really think your kids are  going to be around you in 40 years if  they don't want to be around you right  now right so so every one of those  things has to have a congruency that  comes back for me that is the sort of  defining principle of health span is  sort of understanding cognitively  physically and emotionally what you want  in the last decade of your life  and making sure that you work backwards  from there do you want to be able to  walk up this many flights of stairs do  you want to be able to pick up a child  of this weight from the ground and  what that does is it turns into  basically  um a consolidated set of metrics for  strength and fitness